il est 8h26 c'est l'heure de l'économie
le chiffre d'affaires mais 7h23 mais je
sais pas ce qui m'arrive je vous demande
pardon alors là
[Applaudissements]
le parvis de la mairie est toujours
barricadé ce matin c'est donc dans le
square tout proche que tout se sont
rassemblés pour chanter la Marseillaise
des habitants réunis pour soutenir leur
mère après l'attaque à la voiture bélier
contre son domicile dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche je suis vraiment
désolé 8h24 et 6 secondes Emmanuel le
film
[Rires]
pourrait donc être lourde pour de
nombreux automobilistes mais pas
seulement selon un premier bilan 1000
bâtiments ont été brûlés ou dégradés 250
gendarmerie au commissariat attaqués la
semaine dernière la RATP annonçait à
avoir déjà répertorié plus de 7 millions
d'euros de dégâts essentiellement des
bus et des trams incendiés
la boucherie de ce commerçant est
complètement détruite même sort pour sa
supérette les économies d'une vie
envolée
la semaine que nous avons vécu à
bousculer les idées reçues de ses
biens-pensants l'immigration et le sujet
numéro 1 l'immigration est plus
précisément une certaine immigration
puisque la présence d'une communauté
asiatique ne pose que je sache aucun
souci sur une seule de France comme
beaucoup de ses confrères il n'a plus la
force de parler
ils savent même pas parfois même
pourquoi ils sont réellement assurés et
la première réunion que l'on a faite en
fait Kamel était complètement perdue
mesdames et messieurs soyez certains
d'une seule chose rien ne changera
quelques mètres plus loin le
propriétaire d'une boulangerie découvre
les dégâts sa perte financière est
lourde
c'est comme ça on peut mettre des
solutions sur lesquelles tout le monde
est d'accord mais les gens de 13 ans qui
sautent présents je voulais quand même
rajouter quelque chose à votre liste
direct vous avez raison vous avez direct
mais ça monsieur Leclerc dira non ça ne
changera rien en fait puisque oui les
gens en prison très précisément mais
en fait vous évidemment chaque jour un
peu plus reste de l'enfant puérilité
[Applaudissements]
c'est par les oreilles que ce père de
famille tire son enfant jusqu'à sa
voiture ou plutôt jusqu'à son coffre des
images devenues virales sur les réseaux
sociaux et aussi une hantise pour
certains parents qui appliquent
eux-mêmes un couvre-feu à leurs enfants
désormais après les événements de
cagnotte ont été mises en ligne l'une
pour aider la famille de Naël elle a
déjà rassemblé plus de 160 000 euros et
l'autre pour soutenir le policier
emprisonné et celle là approche les 900
000 euros une cagnotte lancée par Jean
Messia ancien porte-parole d'Éric
Zemmour elle agite les réseaux sociaux
internautes et personnalités politiques
s'indignent et demande sa suppression il
y a plus de bus déjà qu'il y avait rien
là dans vos cités
[Musique]
du web mais toi je te baise tu dis bien
non justement c'est bien ça le malaise
moi je pense que c'est bon ça c'est
assez fin du mois Nanterre on a montré
notre désaccord avec ce qui s'est passé
on a dit tout ce qu'on avait agir enfin
ça y est on a montré notre colère et
enfin je vois pas l'intérêt d'aller
casser autre chose on a montré à la
police que voilà on était tous soudés on
était tous ensemble solidaire je pense
que voilà on a fait notre révolte on a
j'espère on a été entendu enfin voilà il
y a pas besoin de faire plus et de
déranger plus les gens et dans la foulée
bien une lettre très virulente que vous
voyez à l'antenne se mette à circuler
sur les réseaux sociaux elle est
attribuée à Olivier Marchal acteur et
ancien policier et le texte assez
virulent vous l'avez dit reproche à Omar
Sy de critiquer la police il a été
relayé plusieurs centaines de milliers
de fois sur les réseaux sociaux sauf que
sauf que cette lettre est entièrement
fausse Anne-Sophie et il est apparu la
première fois sur facebook tenez-vous
bien en novembre 2020 il y a trois ans
avant de resurgir ces derniers jours et
pour arrêter les frais Olivier Marchal a
dû se fendre d'un démenti vidéo sur les
réseaux sociaux merci de relier pour
tous les gens qui m'aiment et qui savent
que j'ai dit la vérité merci de relayer
cette vidéo et et que ceux qui utilisent
mon nom aillent bien se faire mettre
d'accord bon
[Musique]
alors là je suis complètement sous le
choc Tiago me lève la main dessus
nerveusement je me mets à rigoler mais
je suis tellement surprise en fait et
c'est tellement inhabituel que je ne
sais pas quoi faire il va falloir que je
commence à adapter l'éducation parce que
ça fait quelques jours que je vois des
fois des petits côtés ados en lui mais
la carrément me lever la main dessus sur
quelle planète on vit en fait il a levé
les bras hurlé son plaisir en
franchissant la ligne Victor l'a fait
était passé proche de la victoire il y a
deux jours hier il a surpris les favoris
pour s'offrir le plus beau succès de sa
carrière gagner une étape sur le Tour
c'est un rêve de gosse c'est pour ça
qu'on fait tous du vélo c'est un truc à
cocher et voilà c'est coché j'espère que
il y en aura d'autres mais je vais
vraiment savourer c'est incroyable en
difficulté l'an dernier sur le tour il
n'était même pas sûr de participer j'ai
vraiment su que j'allais lundi là en
fait c'était la course chez moi pour
m'organiser j'avais pas du tout prévu en
fait de partir avant 3 semaines je me
suis dit par contre sur tout te fous pas
la pression quoi cours pour te faire
plaisir on en sait davantage sur l'homme
idéal mais de son côté en couple il est
comment Jonathan
honnêtement je pense qu'il va falloir
que je réapprenne à être en couple parce
que quand on est tout seul depuis si
longtemps on a nos habitudes de vieux
papis et prétendant j'espère ne pas
aller traumatiser
la consécration d'un homme souriant
talentueux tête en l'air aussi selon son
compagnon de chambre Anthony Perez ça
fait une semaine il déconne avec ça me
disant qu'il allait bonne jambe et moi
je le crois pas trop casque il se couche
tard il se lève tard il fait n'importe
quoi et ça marche je comprends rien avec
ce mec il l'a fait avait déjà gagné une
étape sur le Tour d'Italie son succès
d'hier rend encore plus fier son
directeur sportif Thierry Mareschal
c'est un coureur qui est complètement
atypique c'est pas le bon gars sur qu'il
faut parier ça peut être bingo comme ça
peut être fiasco il a besoin de ces
périodes de relâchement mais quand il
est là il s'est gagné les courses